- [Mark] All right, Amado.
Amado where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Amado] I'm from the
MacArthur Park area.
- [Mark] So, L.A basically.
- [Amado] Yeah, like 6th and Alvarado.
Yeah, not far from here.
- [Mark] And you had both
your parents growing up?
- No, my father, he went
to prison when I was three.
My mother raised me and my brothers.
- [Mark] So dad was in prison
for most of your childhood?
- Yeah, until he died.
- [Mark] Oh, really?
What was he in for?
- He was there for a murder.
He killed somebody.
- [Mark] Was he in gangs?
- Yeah, he was a gang member.
Him and my brothers were gang members.
- [Mark] And you avoided it somehow?
- Yes, I did it because of that.
Since I was so much younger,
I was able to see it
from a different perspective,
and decided it wasn't the life for me.
- [Mark] And where did your life go
from there after you left home?
- I went to prison too.
I used to be a lifer.
- [Mark] What were you in prison for?
- I killed somebody when I was 18.
He was a guy that was trying
to kill me and my friend.
He ended up killing my friend.
And, I ended up in the
process of defending myself,
I ended up killing him.
I later on got it
overturned and I got out,
but I did 11 years,
almost 12 years on that.
- [Mark] But it was self-defense?
- It was in self-defense, yeah.
They got me for a manslaughter.
That's what they got me for.
There is no self-defense in California.
- [Mark] No such thing?
- Well, it's what they tell you.
You can't take the law
into your own hands.
You have to find a police officer
or something to help you.
But, I was scared.
I thought he was gonna kill me for sure.
And I just was trying to
fight the best I could,
and I ended up overcoming him.
But it was the way that it
happened that got me in trouble.
After it happened, I was afraid,
and they had to catch me.
So since I ran, it made me look like
I was doing something underhanded.
But I was just scared.
I was young, I was scared.
I didn't want to do the
rest of my life in prison.
- [Mark] How did you kill him?
- I killed him with an ax.
In these older buildings,
there's a lot of those fire axes.
The idea was when he was
chasing me through the building,
my only hope, I have to defend myself.
And, I picked the ax out of the case,
and it's how I killed him.
It was kind of gruesome.
- [Mark] So from 18 'til like 29?
- Yeah.
Actually 31.
I got out when I was 31.
- [Mark] You've been
out for a couple years?
- Yeah.
That's when I got out, 31.
- [Mark] Oh, you got out when you were 31?
- I'm 43 now.
- [Mark] Oh, you're 43?
So today you're living where?
You're on Skid Row?
- I'm on Skid Row.
I just got back from Mexico.
I had a mother who was ill,
and I went to go take care of,
but she lost her battle with cancer.
And, I came back, I buried her.
I came back after I culminated
a relationship that I had out there.
I ended up getting in a relationship
at the time I was taking care of her.
But it didn't work out for us.
So I decided to come back.
I've been back for
about a year and a half.
About a year into coming back,
I started dating somebody.
It just changed my life, you know?
I had a lot of plans before.
I was excited about being
back and doing things again.
But I mean, contracting
HIV changes everything.
Well, at least what I
thought I knew about it.
I'm starting to learn a lot more
about it now that I have it.
I'm starting to look into it.
And when I was growing up,
I mean, it was a death sentence.
If they told you you had
HIV, you were going to die.
And when I found out I was
like, what am I going to do?
Go to school, get a job?
What's the point?
So I started getting high, you know?
And I've never been one to get high,
but it just seemed like the
right thing to do at the time.
Now I'm transitioning even out of that.
And then I'm thinking to
myself, what are you doing?
This is stupid.
You have a limited amount of time.
Do something with yourself.
Being high is not going
to enable me to do that.
I've had to concentrate,
and this is going to be
the fight of my life.
From what I understand now,
I could live a normal life.
If I take care of myself.
And I stop killing myself with drugs,
and just this lifestyle.
So, I'm trying to get out of here.
I was trying to take me
and my girlfriend out,
but she's stuck here.
This is her life.
She loves this.
She loves something about this place.
I don't feel I can save her,
so I have to save myself.
I struggled with that in the beginning,
because I felt bad leaving her behind.
I don't leave people behind to die.
But, I mean, I have to do something,
otherwise I'm going to die with her,
and I can't die out here.
I have to do something.
- [Mark] How did you contract
AIDS in the first place?
- Sleeping with her.
I'm thinking, I mean, I
don't know how you find out
like where you get it from,
but I've never been one to sleep around.
I made it a point to never
sleep with girls out here.
And this girl approached me,
and told me she liked
me and liked my style,
and wanted to have me as a boyfriend.
What did I think?
And I thought to myself,
who am I to deny her?
I know what she she did
and stuff like that.
But she seemed like a nice girl.
Maybe you needed a better example.
So I said, okay, well, you
wanna see where this goes?
About a year into our relationship,
I started seeing how she lived
and how promiscuous she was,
and how she was doing it behind my back.
And I started finding out that the guys
she was sleeping with,
some of these guys had HIV.
So I encouraged her to go
get tested and she did.
And it turns out she did have,
not only HIV, but a bunch of other stuff.
And I didn't want to go get
tested, to get confirmed.
I didn't even go get
tested for like six months.
Because it shocked me when
I found out she had it.
But not like when I found
out I really truly had it.
And I don't know how to
describe what it's like.
I'm just not sure.
It's even embarrassing to
tell friends and family.
You want to tell them to help you,
and you want to explain to them
what's happening in your life,
but it's hard to tell them you have HIV.
It makes you feel dirty.
I don't know, it's just hard.
It's hard to tell them.
So, it's hard to reach
out and ask for help.
But I recently done
that, and it took a lot
of courage to tell them I had HIV.
'Cause I know they're
going to tell other people,
and I'm always going to
be that guy who had AIDS.
I never thought that I would be that guy.
But, we'll see how it goes.
It's hard.
- [Mark] The medications they
have now are great, though.
- Yeah, they can really
save your life, man.
I'm barely starting to find
out still, 'cause like I said,
I'm barely starting to get into
the treatment and everything like that.
So I don't know too much about it.
But I mean there's pills that,
it would basically clean
out my blood and my system
so well that if you test
me, I won't even come out.
And I won't be able to
get my partners infected.
So that means I could maybe start dating.
And I could maybe have a regular life.
Like maybe I could have a
wife, I've never been married.
I don't have kids.
Maybe I can still do that.
And I thought that was not a
possibility for me anymore.
And that has always been
my dream, to have a family.
From what they're telling me,
it looks like I could
still have a normal life
if I start making the changes now,
and I do what I have to do to get better.
If not, it's going to kill me.
I see people out here,
how fast they deteriorate.
It takes them.
I don't want to be taken that way.
Like it took my girl's mother.
She looked healthy, she looked fine.
And then one day she just died.
It's crazy.
I don't want that to be me.
So many people are dying
out here right now.
It's crazy how many people are dying
from all kinds of different stuff.
And tomorrow it could be me.
They can be like, oh, remember that guy?
Yeah.
Oh, he was a nice guy.
Oh yeah, well he died.
Oh, what happened?
He had HIV.
Or, he did die from an overdose.
So whatever it is.
I don't want that to be me.
I want to do better than this.
Maybe come back and
help and inspire others
to do the same thing, show
them that it can be done.
'Cause there's not a lot
of people doing that.
No one ever comes back
and tells you their success story.
I don't ever hear anything like that.
No one ever comes back and tells me,
hey man, it's possible.
Like, this is what you can do.
I think if someone came back and did that,
that would help a lot of people.
It's not over.
This is only the beginning.
I mean, that's the way I feel now.
Now I have something to fight for.
I have something to live for, not die for.
- [Mark] Your attitude is great,
considering the tragedies
that you had to go through.
- Yeah.
I don't have a lot of family.
Like I said, I just lost my mother.
She was like that last real family I had.
So like, I'm alone.
I mean, that's all I need, I guess.
I know that if she found out I had HIV,
it would have broke her heart.
I'm glad that she passed away
and didn't have to find out,
'cause it would have broke her heart.
To find out her youngest son died of AIDS.
'Cause she probably thought of AIDS
in the way I used to think of AIDS.
- [Mark] It's changed a lot.
- Yeah.
It's not like it used to be.
I mean there's commercials
and all kinds of stuff now.
They used to make you feel
like it was dirty before.
It was like only bad people got that.
But I notice now that
anybody can catch it.
It's everywhere.
If you're not careful you can get it.
And you have to really be careful.
I was not careful enough.
I took it for granted and
I had unprotected sex.
And you don't really think about it.
Unprotected sex, oh,
it only takes one time.
You don't think about that.
I never really did, not
took it that seriously.
Once I got to know a girl for awhile,
and I knew her well enough,
yeah, I can have unprotected sex with her.
But that could have been it right there.
Or I could maybe infect other people,
if I was careless like that.
And mess up their lives.
It just changes lots of things for me.
It makes me a lot more conscious.
It makes me a better person.
In a way, it's good that I caught HIV,
because I was not really
living, like I tend to live now.
I still got to find out how bad
I am, or what strain I have.
Those are all things that
I'm waiting for right now.
I'm a little worried about it because
there is parts of AIDS
that is pretty strong,
and they can kill me.
And then maybe I won't
have all the opportunities
that I'm talking about.
But I feel hopeful.
I feel strong.
- [Mark] You look great.
You'd never know you're
sick with anything.
- I don't feel sick at all.
I feel optimistic.
I feel a little bad about my girlfriend,
because she's had a messed up life.
I feel bad for her.
She didn't have the
examples that I had in life.
I had a great mother.
I had good people in my life
that taught me the right things,
that enabled me to have the perspective
that I have about things.
Even though I grew up in
a real bad neighborhood.
I spent most of my life in prison.
I just always had good examples.
I've always been blessed,
to be surrounded by good people.
- [Mark] All right, Amado.
Thank you so much for talking to me,
and sharing your story.
- It's my pleasure, I
hope it helps somebody.
- [Mark] I think it will.
- [Amado] Thank you.